You mean to say you copied someone else's consciousness without federal authorization?
Yes.
Suspect moving fast in sector B-54, all nearby units respond immediately.
My God, don't you know this is a federal felon?
So I found you, I just want to activate it.
The V-1 mind upload had flaws, I can't give it to you.
They're in the copy!
No more clothes!
An unregulated digital consciousness uploaded to the public network?
I can't bear the consequences.
Then why did you help build it?
Listen!
The Omega Life breach still haunts me.
That was a disaster, son.
You know what the rich do with your technology.
Listen, I'm just a scientist, I don't do politics.
All I know is this will tore society apart.
You better check this shit out.
Courts don't need testimony anymore.
Take the scrap if you want it.
Just scrub the serial numbers.
And just so you know, no one's ever put a mind in a machine before.
Think about the next generation.
It's already falling apart out there, Doctor.
I'm not doing this for you.
I'm doing it for them.
I'll ask you one last time.
Are you sure about this?
Hands up! You are arrested!
Hey!
I'm not going to die!
It burns!